so both of you are mothers of black sons
so what kind of conversations
are taking place in your homes right now
uh well i mean it's a normal
conversation a conversation that's
of course been going on since the
beginning of time and
even from the days that we first got
here it's a conversation of being
careful
uh that um when you go out you know
be kind you think about in the 1800s you
know don't
don't make eye contact there's always a
conversation
every generation is different now we
when we say
you know be nice to the police my
brothers were told i'll say yes sir
but now it doesn't matter now it's just
be careful do what you can
you know have all your ducks in a row
the conversation's very my son is nine
years old
so i was hoping that this conversation
wouldn't be around anymore
but every year i see that i have to have
the conversation and my son said to me
when i told him about what happened to
george floyd he said am i going to die
one day
oh my gosh it's a hard thing being uh
yeah it it really no no no go ahead i
was gonna
i'm just gonna say but i just want to
say this what i want to say
to people is my son is like your son
our children are all the same we're
mothers
what they grow up to be men but don't be
afraid of my son don't be afraid of me
we are people we are all people and we
are all just trying to raise our
families
and have good lives go ahead sherry say
what you gotta say ridiculous thing i
think though that you have to
say that kelly it's really it's just
like kim said the piggy bank
it's awful that we're still experiencing
the same thing
that people went through in the 50s and
the 60s when they were marching
and to have to tell our sons we're black
mothers so our prayer is very different
to tell our sons how to survive just to
make it home
is is very anguishing and it's
devastating and just like kim my son
likes the wwe he watches nickelodeon
he's got a great sense of humor and he
just wants a girlfriend
and that's just like anybody else's son
but to know that somebody won't
get to the core of how beautiful he is
because of his skin color
is really frightening to me and you know
we just call for people to speak out
against racism and speak out when you
see something wrong speak out
you know and also you know there's
things in the rooms that you hear that
kim and i won't hear because we're two
black women
we just ask for people when you say what
can we do speak out and say where are
the people of color
behind the scenes that can make a
difference on even you know
tv so that our sons can grow up and be
you know and do what they love like
everybody else's children
no and it's the same thing i think with
like even police brutality it's like hey
okay there are great cops out there but
you're not great if you're just standing
by
like you need to say something like you
have to call people out and
it's got to change so anyway that's
that's why i love i know it's
it's not uncomfortable for me but i know
it can be uncomfortable for some people
especially in the spotlight but i really
appreciate you being very honest and
vulnerable and truthful
because i think that's the only way
people are going to hear you um you know
whoever you are wanting to get your
message
out so anyway thank you for for
discussing that with me i really
appreciate it
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel
please don't make me keep going